echoes of the Arab Spring after nearly a
month of protests the a tutorial put a
flick about to public pressure announced
he will not run for fifth term as
president the news brought tens of
thousands out on the streets to
celebrate but some struck a note of
caution warning that real change must
follow good thing but only if they
change the government completely if they
bring someone just like him it's not
worth it
they have to change the whole government
process as well too wary of the
announcement that they election due to
be held next month has been postponed
indefinitely what does it mean when they
announced that Buddha fleeca is not
running for a fifth term but that he is
adding another year this is what he
wanted from the beginning to postpone
the elections and have another year we
don't want that we want Buddha fleeca
and his plan to give up our Buddha
FeliCa suffered a severe stroke in 2013
and Israeli appeared in public sins but
on Monday algerian TV aired footage of
the ailing president in a meeting that
included nuridium between the current
interior minister who is not considered
part of booty flickers in a circle has
been named the new prime minister
that's being seen as a sign that the old
guard might really be releasing its hold
on power joining us now from Algiers to
Sofia UNASUR journalist following events
there good morning Sofia are the
celebrations we've been seeing in
Algiers premature and will buddha
flicker really leave office the
relations that we've seen yesterday
night are definitely premature and what
we've seen yesterday night was a service
or thousands of people who are going out
but the majority of those who were had
into the streets in recent weeks stayed
home yesterday as they know very well
that the move and the announcements made
by beautiful-ass clan yesterday are
simply a political maneuver this is not
a real political change it's worth
noting that
the suggestion of organizing a national
conference on consensus what was already
put forward by allies of with the
speaker in December so this is not an
useful new suggestion a new solution to
solve the ongoing crisis they were
trying to build new consensus within the
regime for months so the suggestion of a
National Conference of consensus is not
more than a political maneuver to stay
in power and to keep things running
now sofiane what was behind the decision
to postpone April's a presidential
election have a look at the the way how
the Algerian regime is working we're not
talking about the dictatorship we're not
talking about an autocratic regime we're
talking about the semi-automatic regime
composed of several wings and what we're
witnessing for quite a while is a power
struggle between several of these wings
so when Whitaker was reelected in 2014
these wings couldn't agree on another
candidates or but the teacher was kind
of an emergency solution because they
couldn't find another candidate so
they're buying time they're buying time
to find another candidate that would be
able to please as many wings as possible
during regions
okay so a lot of movement there in the
background in Algiers
Sofia Nassau for us thanks very much